drop out does this seemingly crazy thing
of randomly knocking out eun-seo Network
why does it work so well as a regulator
let's gain some better intuition in the
previous video I gave this intuition
that drop out randomly knocks out units
your network so it's as if on every
iteration you're working with the
smaller neural network and so using a
smaller neural network seems like it
should have a regular izing effect
here's the second intuition which is you
know let's look at it from the
perspective of a single unit all right
let's say this one now for this unit to
do is job as for input then needs to
generate some meaningful output now with
dropout the inputs can get randomly
eliminated you know sometimes those two
units will get eliminated sometimes a
different unit will get eliminated so
what these are at this unit which I'm
circling purple it can't rely on any one
feature because any one feature could go
away at random or any one of its own
influence could go away in random so in
particular be reluctant to put all of
this bets on say just this input right
the ways we reluctant to put too much
weight on any one input because army can
go away so this unit would be more
motivated to straight out this weight
and give you a little bit of weight to
each of the four inputs to this unit and
by spreading all the weights
this will tend to have an effect of
shrinking the squared norm of the waste
and so similar to what we saw with l2
regularization the effect of
implementing dropout is that it strings
aways and does similar to l2
regularization it helps to prevent
overfitting but it turns out that
dropout can formerly be shown to be an
adaptive form of l2 regularization but
the l2 penalty on different waves are
different depending on the size of the
activations being multiplied into that
weight but to summarize it is possible
to show that dropout has a no similar
effect to l2 regularization only the l2
regularization applied to different ways
can be a little bit different and even
more adaptive than scale of different
inputs one more detail
when you're implementing dropout she's a
network where you have three input
features this is 7 7 units 0 7 3 2 1 so
one of the parameters we have to choose
was the cheap profit which is a charm to
keeping a unit in each layer so it is
also feasible to very key prop by layer
so for the first layer your matrix W 1
will be 3 by 7
your second weight matrix will be 7 by 7
W 3 will be 7 by 3 and so on and so W 2
is actually the biggest weight matrix
right those are actually the largest of
the parameters will be in W 2 which is 7
by 7 so to prevent to reduce over
setting of that matrix maybe for this
layer I guess this is layer 2 you might
have a cheap cost as relatively low say
0.5 where's 4 different layers where you
might worry less well just again you
could have a higher key problem in
reducing 0.7 maybe this is 0.7 and if
the layers we don't worry about
overfitting at all you can have a keep
drop of 1.0 right so you know for
clarity these are numbers I'm drawing in
the purple boxes these could be
different key prompts for different
layers notice that the key problem 1.0
means that you're keeping every unit and
so you're really not using broad drop
out for that layer but the layers where
you're more worried about overfitting
really the layers of all the parameters
you could say key prompt to be smaller
to apply a more powerful form of dropout
it's kind of like cranking up the
regularization parameter lambda of l2
regularization when you try to
regularize some layers more than others
and technically you can also apply
dropout to the input layer where you can
have some cons of you know just acting
on one or more of the input features
although in practice usually don't do
that that often and so Chih problem 1.0
is quite common for the input layer you
might also use a very high value is 0.9
but it's much less likely that you know
you
once eliminate half of the input
features so usually key problem if you
apply that all will be a number close to
one if you even apply dropout at all to
the input layer so just to summarize if
you are more worried about some layers
overfitting than others you can set a
lower key prop for some layers than
others
the downside is this gives you even more
hyper parameters to search for using
cross-validation one other alternative
might be to have some layers where you
apply dropout in some ways we don't
apply dropout and in terms of one hyper
parameter which is the key prop for the
layers for which you do apply dropout
and before we wrap up just a couple
implementational tips many of the first
successful implementations of dropouts
were to computer vision so in computer
vision the input size is so big you in
putting all these pixels that you almost
never have enough data and so dropout is
very frequently used by it in computer
vision and there are some conservation
researchers that pretty much always use
it almost as a default but really the
thing to remember is that dropout is a
regularization technique it helps
prevent overfitting and so unless my
algorithm is over fitting I wouldn't
actually bother the use drop also is
used somewhat less often than other
application areas it's just the computer
vision you know you usually just don't
have an update or so you're almost
always overfitting which is why they
tend to be some computer vision
researchers square by drop out by the
intuition always doesn't always
generalize I think to other disciplines
one big downside of dropouts is that the
cost function J is no longer well
defined on every iteration they are
randomly you know killing off a bunch of
nodes and so if you are double checking
the performance or gradient descent it
is actually harder to double check that
and you have a well-defined cost
function J that is going downhill on
every iteration because the cost
function J that you're optimizing is
actually less less well defined there is
a surfing hard to calculate so you lose
the debugging tool through the plot a
graph like this
so what I usually do is turn off drop
out of you will set key property equals
one and it run my code make sure that it
is monotonically decreasing J and then
turn on dropout and hope that you know I
didn't introduce a welcome to my code
during drop out because you need other
ways I guess but not plotting these
figures to make sure that your code is
working the Granderson is working even
with drop out so with that there are so
a few more regularization techniques
that work your knowing let's talk about
a few more such techniques in the next
video